when you look at the Mount Charleston
Lodge not only includes the possibility
of a new restaurant but maybe even a new
hotel you might recall the Lodge at the
end of Kyle Canyon Road was destroyed by
fire September of 2021. and Mary Jane
bellies shares how residents are
reacting and what this could mean for
their town
it's been more than a year since the
Mount Charleston Lodge burned down it
was a home away from home for Valley
locals and hikers so in the announcement
of a new Lodge was in the works we're
all excited for a new Lodge to be built
fill fill a hole that was
that that happened when the the lodge
burnt down many residents eager to see
what would become of the Historic Site
resident Boca attended the Mount
Charleston Town Advisory board meeting
on December 1st Boca says there is some
pushback from Old Town residents about
the possibility of a new hotel going up
at the lodge the only concerns I think a
lot of us have are they want to put a
hotel in which would bring a lot of
traffic and
you know we have water issues and
ecological impacts that might come from
that they said maybe it'd be about 30 to
34 rooms
um and we had a meeting down at the
library at a community meeting and they
wanted to get some feedback
um and a bunch of us in the community
are very opposed to the hotel but very
excited about a rebuilding of the lodge
nationally Ryan agrees with Boca she
moved to Mount Charleston two years ago
so I think that there are some concerns
from the residents just for many reasons
light pollution being one of them
um just extra traffic on a already
notoriously dangerous road I think
especially during the winter time there
are a lot of animals and I think that a
lot of folks don't know you know not to
walk up to the horses and things like
that while Boca understands the long
development project ahead she hopes
residents concerns will be considered of
course this is residential area and they
don't have the permits for that and it's
likely that they won't get it I know
that there's going to be a big fight
from the residents here if they try to
do that but we're very supportive of a
rebuild of a lodge
8 news now reached out to the owners of
the Mount Charleston Lodge which is
Ellis Island while there are no
interviews about potential plans at this
time we did receive this statement they
say they've been working on it for the
past year but they are still in the
initial stages end quote we shared our
vision including conceptual plans and
renderings we look forward to working
with the community and Clark County to
re-establish the Mount Charleston Lodge